Các mề ra ghi lại cảnh người dan ông truy qua cơ quấn, dùng buốt cấp tiệp vang.
Chương mây tám thức bây khi chủ tiệp vang miệng vĩnh phát ở sám y tủ,
trong bị đống cơ, lê chỉ hiểu buốt mấy mốt tội, dựng sai trước cơ,
rồi truy qua khai cơ quấn vào bên trong.
Lúc này trong tiệp có chủ tiệp cùng con trải và con rau.
Tức cận quay trưng bây, hiểu dùng buốt đập bởi tụ gính, lấy năm sợi dây chuyển vang, rồi bỏ trải.
Tuy nhiên, tên cấp bị ra đình chủ tiệp, người dân và con ăn có mặt gần đó không trế, bắt giữ.
Tòan bộ gần tám chỉ vang với năm bởi bây kia, chỉ giá khoảng 1 trong trộ đầu đã được thu hội.
Bước đầu hiểu khai zong nợ nần không còn khả năng trị trả, nên trở bị buốt và tuy sách để ghi ăn.
Công ăn sả mỹ tủ đang tạm giữ hiểu để điều tra về hành vi cấp tài xa.